je me suis trompé d'objectif pour ma vie
et un jour à 28 ans je me suis cassé le
sacrum en tombant d'un tabouret de bar à
9 heures du matin plusieurs semaines
bloquées dans mon lit et là j'ai
réfléchi moi qui n'arrête jamais je
n'avais pas le choix
rien d'autre à faire cette expérience a
changé le cours de ma vie mais revenons
en arrière
tout a commencé à 12 ans pas ma passion
pour le japon
j'avais la certitude que ma vie
s'écrirait dans ce pays sa culture son
histoire ses coutumes j'ai tout étudié
j'ai voyagé du nord au sud
j ai travaillé j'ai appris la langue et
même grimper le mont fuji retour brutal
en france pour terminer mes études
et pourtant un seul objectif construire
ma vue au japon tout d'abord j'ai
cherché à une profession qui pourrait me
permettrait de voyager je choisissais
l'hôtellerie de brèves études
mam nerthe intégré la compagnie hyatt à
19 en renonçant à d'autres propositions
plus alléchantes qui trouvait une
ambiance jeune dynamique
j'avais trouvé ma maison je savais
également khayat avait cinq hôtels au
japon et favoriser les échanges
la brochure vente est qu au bout de un
an et un jour un employé pouvez demander
sa mutation
ainsi après un an et un jour je
demandais fièrement mme au départ pour
le japon
hayat me conseillaient d'attendre et de
construire ma carrière réceptionniste
puis chef d'equipe puis directrice de
nuit du chef de réception
et pourtant je n'avais absolument aucune
ambition
chaque évolution a été une surprise
la culture d'entreprise américaine peut
paraître étonnante pour un européen
seuls ceux que l'on démontre compte
l'âge l'ancienneté les études l'origine
sociale
tout cela ne rentre jamais
considération trois ans après je
retournais à la charge
car j'avais toujours le japon en ligne
de mire
au pire la vie l'attend a duré un an et
hayat a été très heureux d'accéder à ma
demande
un beau matin et de me proposer la
mutation dans un pays tout proche du
japon le maroc
ma déception passée j'ai compris que
j'avais besoin d'enrichir je ne
connaissais pas le maroc
j accepte l aventure et le mot est bien
choisi car j'allais en vivre des
aventures au maroc je débarquais donc
avec mes petites valises mais 24 ans
molowny planète à casablanca au poste de
chef de réception tout cela était bien
loin de tokyo nouvelle culture
appréhender nouvelles coutumes et
j'évolue est désormais dans un pays
religieux le quotidien n'était pas
simple jeune étrangère non musulmanes
femme est blonde dix années marocaine ou
sans l'avoir demandé ma carrière évoluer
jusqu'à finir à 30 ans directrice de
l'hôtel ceux qui ont travaillé tôt maroc
se rejoignent pour dire que manager dans
ce pays n'est pas simple c'est une école
de patience de persévérance et de
vigilance
très vite les employés que vous gênez
cherche à vous écartez vous me direz
c'est partout pareil
oui mais dans un pays religieux il ya
des arguments qui peuvent devenir
dangereux on m'accuse à un jour d'avoir
jeté un courant et une photo du roi dans
une poubelle
cette accusation paraissait improbable
qu'elle veut peut vous sembler anodine
ce n'est pas le cas au maroc c'est une
affaire grave sans que les faits soient
établis du jour au lendemain
l'ensemble des employés marocains ne
m'adressait plus un mot j'ai été écouté
par les renseignements une enquête en
vue de mon expulsion était diligentée le
rêve marocain tournait au cauchemar
ce qui ne tue pas rend plus fort ce qui
ne tue pas rend plus fort chaque jour je
me le répétait comme un mantra c'est
dans ce contexte délétère que ma bouée
de sauvetage arrivent à hayat
menault ma directrice générale adjointe
ce geste fort envers les employés est
également un effet radical envers les
autorités
cependant je reste est soupçonnée est
fiché cela complique à la suite vous
allez comprendre
mais revenons à notre tabouret de bar
cette chute me clouer au lit pendant
deux semaines l'ennui total
à tel point que je pris le temps de
faire le point je me suis imaginé à 40
ans et j'ai imaginé quelle serait ma vie
selon le chemin qui s'annonçait et je me
suis posé la question est ce que j'ai le
sentiment de réussir ma vie
côté professionnel je n'aurais pu
espérer mieux j'étais maintenant dire à
la direction d'un hôtel cinq étoiles et
selon toute vraisemblance un poste de
directrice générale m'attendais tôt ou
tard
côté personnel le grand vide
créée ce qui comptait avant tout pour
moi simplement comme beaucoup d'entre
vous être mère avoir des enfants
c'était évident essentiel vital seul au
maroc depuis des années un poste prenant
aucun prétendant à l'horizon la marche
rapide du temps les avait un risque
important de ne pas y parvenir
quelle option avait trouvé un homme avec
qui fondent et ma famille je ne
demandais pas mieux mais jusque là je
n'avais pas été très doué l'insémination
cela ne correspondait pas
l'adoption un chemin si compliqué
d'autant plus pour une femme seule il
faut croire que le chemin compliqué
deux ans plus tard remise de ma chute
les idées plus claires sur le sens que
je voulais donner à ma vie je me suis
retrouvé au milieu du désert sahraouis
ouvrant grand les bras à noa noa ma
fille un petit bébé de 8 mois au regard
grave et profond à cet instant précis je
trouvais la sérénité et la paix
intérieure
j'oubliais les démarches
l'incompréhension de mes parents j'avais
dû me convertir à l'islam
noah dans mes bras j'étais une maman sa
maman pour autant mes problèmes avec les
autorités marocaines n'étaient pas
terminées j'étais toujours fichiers
comme rebelle par la police et on
refusait de me donner les papiers ceylan
l'adoption je me suis retrouvé menacé de
devoir rendre mon bébé et je me suis
retrouvé assigné à résidence pendant une
semaine dans le sahara aucun marocain ne
voulait m'aider car m'aider aurait pu
être interprété comme une prise de
position contre la royauté ou la
religion les mois passaient et les
menaces de nous séparer devenait de plus
en plus régulières je me suis alors
souvenu d'un dicton qui dit faire de son
ennemi son meilleur ami
je voulais appliquer on alla voir ce qui
avait porté plainte contre moi je leur
ai expliqué que cela en
j'ai mon affectation dans un autre hôtel
hyatt loin du maroc comme c'est personne
n'attendait qu'une seule chose que je
libère la place ils sont intervenus et
en un mois mon problème était résolu
cela a constitué une période
merveilleuse de ma vie un bonheur
immense
no et moi étions fusionnelle peut-être
trop
afin d'apporter de l' équilibre à notre
relation mais aussi parce que je rêvais
d'une famille et non un duo je lançais
les démarches en vue de donner un jour
une petite soeur à noah
en parallèle je n'étais tout pas faire
et du tout à l'idée de rencontrer un
homme qui pourrait compléter notre
famille pas du tout mais il fallait
trouver cet homme qui comprendrait
mechouar et les accepterai côté pro tout
allait très bien ma carrière continuer
j'étais maintenant au poste de
directrice
j'étais sur la liste des transferts
j'attendais donc un beau matin je me
suis dit qu'il était temps d'adopter mon
deuxième enfant j'en informer mes
parents qui cette fois ci se sont
insurgées de manière beaucoup plus
virulente que la première fois pour mon
père je gâchais définitivement ma vie il
est est ébranlé pour ma mère je
relançais l'aider et je joue avec le feu
qu'importe
j'avais mes convictions et personne
n'aurait pu me faire changer d'avis je
connaissais les difficultés qui
m'attendait mais j'étais prête à les
affronter
prête à tout revivre pour continuer ma
route et fondé ma famille coûte que
coûte
quelques mois plus tard la magie opérait
à nouveau et j'ai donné à ma fille est
née une petite soeur ma et pour la
seconde fois de ma vie je pleurais de
choix
l'année suivante je prenais la direction
de l'hôtel du louvre et nous rentrions
dont toutes les trois à paris et c'est
ainsi qu'après 10 ans mon aventure
marocaine pris fin à cette occasion
j'aimerais remercier le maroc pour deux
raisons tout d'abord j'ai la certitude
que les obstacles qui se sont dressés
sur mon chemin ont fait grandir et m'ont
emmené là où j'en suis aujourd'hui dans
ma vie professionnelle
ensuite le maroc m'a donné la
possibilité de réaliser mon rêve
être maman le maroc m'a permis de
découvrir quelque chose de très
paradoxale qui constitue peut-être un
enseignement c'est précisément sur les
enjeux les plus essentiels de notre vie
que nous devons parfois accepter de
lâcher prise et faire confiance au
destin en l'occurrence pour ma part
c'est au sujet de la parentalité
pourtant central dans ma vie que je m'en
suis remise au destin et celui ci a été
plus que bienveillant et généreux avec
moi et ce n'est pas fini
noah âgé de 4 ans voulait vraiment que
je trouve un amoureux et qu'elle est
ainsi un papa elle se démenait à me
trouver quelqu'un un passant dans la rue
un voisin peu importe dès qu'elle voyait
un homme elle me le conseillait c'était
parfois amusant souvent gênant
cependant sa volonté prix bas je me suis
inscrite sur internet sans réelle
motivation
et pourtant le destin était en marche
quarante huit heures après mon
inscription je répondais à un seul
message et rencontrer enfin l'homme de
ma vie
noah et marc avec un papa et même une
grande soeur issu d'un premier mariage
aujourd'hui je dirige toujours l'hôtel
du louvre
cela fait maintenant 17 ans que je
m'épanouis au sein de la compagnie hayat
j'aime toujours autant le japon j'y vais
tous les ans et mes enfants parlent
couramment japonais
quand même nous vivons tous les cinq
et je peux définitivement répondre un
grand oui à la question m la conviction
de réussir ma vie
pour finir j'aimerais très humblement
vous livrer les deux enseignements que
je retirais de mon parcours le premier
et ne vous trompez pas d'objectif pour
votre vie et ne courais pas après ce qui
n'est pas véritablement fondamental pour
vous et le deuxième
n'attendez pas de tomber d'un tabouret
et d'être bloqués dans votre lit pour
vous demander ce qui donne vraiment du
sens à votre vie
merci